[Musique]
arcadia est une vraie pépinière
d'activité surnaturel
il y à un autre monde sous nos pieds
dont on ne sait rien des créatures
vivant dans l'ombre des monstres vivent
parmi nous je ne sais pas ce que c'est
mais quelqu'un ou quelque chose arcadia
est au centre de tout ça promet la vache
une nouvelle mission pour les chasseur
de troll pour rentrer l'adage croit
ouais mais en vrai j'ai pas tout écouté
il parlait super vite que de lavage
quand on va s'en sortir
les arbitres à portée de main c'est
impossible
la morte après à toutes les portes
arcadia ne serait qu'un tas de cendres
on doit essayer de l'empêcher on est
plus fort à plusieurs
[Musique]
ce serait jouable avec un warhammer de
poche attendez voir que dire c'est trop
que j'enlève désolé les gars
[Musique]
le solaire la corde sont affaiblis sens
venez
accrochez vous
let a fait de toine authentique chasseur
de troll tu es devenu un héros
[Musique]
gaboury tondu qui loge